-Paul.
-Thank you.
Good to see you, Jimmy.
-It is great to see you.
Dude, you look great, as always.
Look at you on the cover
of Men's Health magazine...
-Oh.
[ Cheering and applause ]
...looking like a stud.
[ The Roots playing
"Celebration" ]
-No, no, no, no, no, no.
We can't --
-Whoo! Whoo!
-Thank you!
You know, now,
you're embarrassing me.
-No.
-Bringing out Men's Health
already, out of the gate.
[ Laughter ]
-No, I did it on your intro.
-Very sweet of you.
-You're a stud.
This is awesome.
You know, it's funny, because
your costar Jonathan Majors
also was on the cover
of Men's Health.
-Yeah. It's strange, because,
normally, you're doing a movie
and they ask you to do
a magazine cover
and here we are, Men's Health.
But, this time,
they did both of us,
both actors from the movie.
-Were you worried that it'd be
similar photographs?
-Similar. A little.
I mean, a little bit because,
you know,
I don't know if you've seen
Men's Health.
They sometimes will --
they'll kind of have
a similar setup
but I'm like, "Ah,
is this going to be too alike?"
-Right, right, right.
I actually have --
I have his cover as well
-Right.
-Of Men's Health.
[ Laughter ]
If you want to just take a --
We'll look at both.
-Well, you'll see --
you'll get what I'm saying.
-Yeah.
I think that like there's a --
-Here's his cover right here.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-It's a real --
[ The Roots playing funky jazz ]
[ Cheering ]
-Yeah.
So -- So, they were like --
they assured me.
They'll say, "Don't worry.
It's not going to be the same,"
and I see he's by a pool,
so, I was like, "Oh, okay."
[ Laughter ]
-They're different.
I'm against a wall --
-They're different enough.
-I'm against a wall.
He's at a pool, yeah.
-I went further,
if you don't mind.
I actually looked inside the
magazine at the photo shoots
and see how similar
your shoots are.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, right.
-Like they have casual shots
of you, alright, in the mag.
Here's a casual shot
of Jonathan.
-So, there's Jonathan.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Hey, now.
-There's
Jonathan's casual shot.
-Dude chilling out.
He probably didn't even know
the camera was there.
-Yeah. Yeah, I know.
It's like he's just hanging out
-By the pool.
-by the pool, again,
and I'm like, "Well,
what about my casual shot?"
-Yeah, and here's your --
this is your casual shot.
"Stay with the wall."
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
-That's very similar
to the cover.
-It's kind of --
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Similar.
-It's similar.
It's similar, but this one,
you can see, it's like --
"Oh, what --
Oh, hey!"
[ Laughter and applause ]
-You recognize.
At first,
you didn't know who they were.
-It's like, "Wait, hold on,
you're shooting a picture, what?
Oh, you guys!"
[ Laughter and applause ]
-But then there's a --
then there's a --
there's a thing in Jonathan's
where they go
through his morning routine.
-Yeah, that's another thing
they like to do.
They want to, you know,
just make you appear
as you normally are,
just, you know,
you get ready for the day or --
-Getting up.
-Yeah, and here's --
so, here's Jonathan with his --
he's having a protein shake.
[ Laughter and applause ]
And --
Then, here --
-So, he's drinking his -- yeah.
-Yeah, he's drinking
his protein.
And here's you
with a glass of juice.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Cheering ]
[ Rimshot ]
-Yeah, so --
so, it's kind of the same.
They were like, "Do you want --
What do you want,
like chamomile tea
or something?"
[ Laughter ]
And I was like,
"What am I, a wimp?
No! I want a --"
-This one, though,
this one really made me laugh.
This one made me laugh
because this is the best.
This is him like working out.
-Yeah.
-I've never seen --
I've never seen this
in my lifetime.
-Yeah.
-Here he is.
[ Laughter ]
He's hanging upside-down
on a workout bar
or something, doing ab crunches.
-It's health and fitness.
They want to see you,
you know, working out.
-Yeah. And then here's
your workout photo.
-Yeah.
-You're holding
a ten-speed bicycle.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Cheering ]
-Is that a thing?
-You're not even riding it.
-No, no, no. Well, I was like,
"Should I ride it?"
They're like, "Why don't you --
Why don't you lift it up?"
And I'm like, "This is --"
-You're not even riding
the bike.
[ Laughter ]
-No, no. I mean, you know,
it's health --
it's, you know,
health and fitness.
I got to --
-Yeah.
-And that's, by the way,
that's like an old-school
ten-speed bike.
That's not one
of these newfangled,
[ Laughter ]
light, kind of mountain bikes
made of, yeah, graphite.
-This one weighs a lot.
Are you on a rooftop there?
-Yes, I am.
[ Laughter ]
I'm on a roof of a building,
which, doesn't everyone
carry their bike
up to the roof of a building?
[ Laughter ]
I mean --
-Why?
Are you getting the bike
off the roof
and getting ready
to hit the streets?
-That's exactly right.
I'm like --
[ Laughter ]
-You lock it up there,
so no one touches it.
-That was my understanding.
I'm like --
-How did the bike get
to the roof of the building?
-"I guess I'm carrying
my bike up to the roof?"
-Oh, that's pretty good.
Yeah.
You get exhausted from that.
-Maybe I'm just
taking it downstairs.
I'd probably take it downstairs.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, of course you do.
-It's too heavy to go up a --
-Well, anyways,
congratulations on this.
I want to talk about "Ant-Man"
and get into all of the stuff.
I loved it.
I saw it the other night.
It's giant.
It's exactly what you want
in a movie.
It's a good popcorn movie.
It is massive, this one.
-Mm.
-But, first, we have to talk
about the Super Bowl.
The Kansas City Chiefs
versus the Philadelphia Eagles.
You are Kansas City all the way.
You're from there.
I know that you --
Are you excited about this?
-I mean, I'm --
you know, I'm nervous.
I'm sitting across
from all you guys.
I know you guys are --
you hate me right now, right?
[ Laughter and applause ]
-No, no, no.
They're friendly.
What are you like?
-I mean, it's --
it's a terrible experience to --
I mean, I'm so nervous.
I'm excited.
I'm thrilled that they're
in the Super Bowl.
I tell you one thing,
I hate those puppies.
[ Laughter ]
But --
-You can't go down --
-First time I've ever --
ever in my life --
-Never said that.
No, yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Stupid puppies!
-No, they're actors,
they're actors.
I'm sorry. I don't know what
this is on my desk.
-What is that?
-It's my mustache.
Is it yours?
I don't know.
There was tape on my desk.
Here.
-What is it?
[ Laughter ]
It's just a piece of tape.
-Remember when like --
Was it --
[ Laughter ]
Can you do that with that?
It's a very thin piece of tape.
-I don't think so.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, that's pretty good.
Yeah, that's pretty good.
Did you just sneeze?
[ Laughter ]
Paul, do you need a tissue?
Paul, here.
-But, anyway, the Super Bowl,
it's going to be a great --
It's going to be a really --
-No, I know, it's going to be
exciting, but -- ooh.
[ Laughter ]
I'll get it.
-Wait.
-Yeah, do it, right.
Why don't you talk
about "Ant-Man."
-[ Faux sneezes ]
-Oh, God bless you.
God bless you.
-Okay. So, anyway --
-No, [indistinct].
[ Laughter and applause ]
No, no, no, not that nose.
-The thing about "Ant-Man" is,
you know, it's a serious film.
-It is?
-And, I mean, this is --
it's different than the others.
-Look at the clip over there.
Maybe the clip is --
-The other "Ant-Man" films
are kind of like
small family films
and then this one
is like just --
[ Laughter and applause ]
-This is, yeah.
Wow!
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Rimshot ]
-Paul, Paul.
-It's huge in scale.
[ Laughter and applause ]
It's just absolutely huge
in scale.
-Did you [indistinct]
Paul, Paul.
[ Laughter ]
Paul, here, here.
Absolutely, yeah.
-Thank you very much.
-Thank you for coming on.
I appreciate that.
[ Laughter ]
-Thank you very much.
-You have a little
something over here. Yeah.
The other side.
Thank you, yeah.
-Did I get it?
-Yeah.
-I'll get it, yeah.
I'll get it.
There you go.
-Pfft!
[ Laughter ]
-Okay. Thank you.
I want to talk about this --
-People, by the way --
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Thank you for doing that.
-People --
Did it look real?
-Yeah, of course.
-Are people going to like
flip on and think that's real?
-Yeah, of course.
-Great.
-That's fun.
[ Laughter ]
You always come on
and do a fun bit.
And then we'll get
to the real meat and potatoes
of the interview here.
It's "Ant-Man,"
"Ant-Man and the Wasp:
Quantumania."
[ Cheering and applause ]
I saw it.
It is fantastic.
It is giant.
-Thank you, yeah.
-It's massive.
I mean, is it --
I don't know.
Is it tough to be involved
in a set that's all CGI?
-There were some days there was
the thing called volume.
And some days we would film
and people said,
[ Whispering ]
"You know, we're going to film
the volume."
And the volume is
a new technology.
You know, normally you're
shooting with bluescreens
all around you,
but it's this --
it's like an LED screen
that wraps
around an entire sound stage.
And so they try and make it feel
as much like the quantum realm
or whatever and we have
something to react to.
And it was crazy
to go into these sound stages
and it looked like you were
in outer space, something wild.
-And what is the ground like?
Is it the ground --
-They put on dirt.
They like have dirt
and they try and have as much
practical stuff as possible.
-So you really feel like you're
on a planet or whatever.
-You really feel like you're
on a planet
or you're in some weird space.
One of the things that --
Actually, we went in
and there was dirt all
over the floor
and we were shooting with like
150 other creatures and people
and it doesn't smell good
at all.
[ Laughter ]
"Mm."
And then throughout the day,
it was kind of getting worse
and worse.
The next day,
it was like overbearing
and we realized they probably
got a deal on the dirt
because it actually wasn't dirt.
It was manure.
[ Ohhs and laughter ]
-What?!
Are you kidding me?
-No.
-Wow!
-They actually had to kind of
shut it down for a day
and then bring in some new dirt.
I don't think anyone knew
and it was --
-You'd think manure would be
more expensive than dirt.
-Apparently not.
-Apparently not!
-Yeah. Yeah. Yeah,
the quantum realm just reeks.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Wow! I did not know that.
-Yeah, yeah.
-Paul, how do we set up
this film?
I would say it's just
action adventure comedy.
It's family-friendly.
-Yeah.
-A lot of family.
It's a little bit like --
You know, family was,
I think, a theme in the other
"Ant-Man" movies, and comedy,
and I think some of that exists
in this one, too,
but it's
on a much grander scale.
It's starting off Phase 5
of Marvel, which --
-Whoa!
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Which is very exciting,
introducing a new
big, bad villain called
Kang the Conqueror.
-Yeah.
-Which is, if you look
at those pictures of Jonathan,
I think you could probably
buy him as a conqueror.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, that's Kang.
-He's fantastic.
-He really is.
-And so, yeah --
-Everyone's great.
-It just feels like a much --
-Michelle Pfeiffer is fantastic.
[ Cheering ]
-She's always great.
-Evangeline Lilly.
-Great.
-Bill Murray.
-How about that?
-Yeah.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Yeah. Awesome.
-Come on.
And you! And you got you.
-And Michael Douglas.
-And Michael Douglas, too.
The whole cast is --
-And Kathryn Newton,
who was here.
-By the way, she hit a home run
in this movie.
She's phenomenal.
-How great is she?
-Everyone's going to fall
in love with her.
-Yeah. She's awesome.
-It's really good that you get
sent into the quantum realm
through this thing
that your daughter invents.
It's like a beacon that she
shouldn't have sent out.
And then you -- I don't want
to explain what really --
-I think you just did.
-Yeah, I did.
[ Laughter ]
And then you got to --
-Marvel will be thrilled.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-I want to show --
-They don't really care, though.
They're, like,
"Tell whatever you want."
They don't mind. It's so weird.
Marvel doesn't care
what you say, yeah.
-They love it.
They really love it, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Sorry, Marvel. It's really good.
I want to show a clip.
Here's Paul Rudd
in "Ant-Man and the Wasp:
Quantumania."
Take a look at this.
[ Cheering ]
-"Do I miss the action?
Sometimes.
Will I be there
when the Avengers need me?
Absolutely.
I'd never turn my back on them.
But right now, the only job
I want is being a dad.
I love you, Cassie.
Thanks for being my hero.
And I'm sorry
I missed some birthdays.
[ Awws ]
And, for the rest of you kids
out there,
word of advice --
look out for the little guy."
-Yeah.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-You're at a book signing.
-Yeah, yeah, I probably
should've said that,
shouldn't I? I guess, yeah.
Scott Lang wrote a book after,
to tell everybody
what's been going on with the,
you know,
the events of "Endgame"
and everything.
-The thing I like about you
and your character in this
is that you do play --
you're the first kind of,
in my mind, a funny superhero
dad type of character,
where you're just --
it's very --
your scenes are so comedic
and funny
and your dynamic
with your daughter.
I don't want to, again, spoil,
but, you crush it, buddy.
-Well, thank you,
Jimmy, thank you.
-You crush it.
I want -- The movie's going
to be huge all over the world
and I want to make sure
that everyone,
all audiences everywhere,
get to hear you talk about it.
So, if you don't mind,
I'm going to do a new thing,
a new technology.
It's called live dubbing, okay?
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-And we've never done this,
right on the show.
I have this remote here, okay?
And it will switch languages
every time I hit a button.
[ Laughter ]
-Wow. Oh, alright.
-So, you want to try it?
-Yeah.
-Here to talk about the new
movie "Ant-Man" is Paul Rudd.
Tell us about "Ant-Man."
-Alright. Well, sure.
You know,
in "Quantumania,"
I play Scott Lang, aka Ant-Man,
and, you know, my family are...
[ Laughter ]
-Straight bussin', no cap.
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Ant-Man" is low-key GOATed
when seeing an exciting movie
is the vibe.
Thanks, fam!
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Paul Rudd, everyone!
"Ant-Man and the Wasp:
Quantumania"
is in theaters and IMAX
February 17th.
Marc Maron joins us
after the break.
Stick around, everybody.